Usually if something’s too good to be true,
it’s a sham.
Like a fuel cell that pulls CO2 out of the
air sounds as likely as a unicorn.
Well, get ready to believe in unicorns.
Hi there, power hungry maniacs, Julian here
for DNews.
We talk a lot about energy production here
at DNews, and with good reason; the comfortable
way we live in developed countries is impossible
without a huge amount of energy, but to make
it we often end up damaging the environment
and lower our quality of life.
Two steps forward, one step back.
Clean and renewable sources of energy are
gaining ground, but in the US natural gas
is still #2 behind dat king coal.
According to the US Energy Information Association,
Coal produced 39% of our energy and Natural
gas made another 27% in 2013.
Coal and Natural gas have the advantage of
being cheap, well established, and don’t
have the problem of intermittency.
The drawback is their byproducts are harmful
to air quality and contribute to climate destabilization.
So if they’re making harmful gasses, why
not just capture the gas and put it underground?
I know that sounds like a stupid question,
but it’s actually one potential fix.
Older methods of Carbon Capture and Storage
used steam from the plants to compress CO2.
But that steam is what drives turbines to
make electricity so to keep up with demand
coal plants would have to burn 25-40% more
fuel.
Then the price of energy goes up and coal
gets used faster, making it infeasible.
Now however, a company called FuelCell Energy
believes they have a solution.
Using a carbonate fuel cell, The CO2 in the
plant’s exhaust is converted into carbonate
ions, then they’re passed through an electrolyte
layer and converted back into CO2.
This generates electricity and concentrates
the CO2 from 13% to about 70%.
If it’s more concentrated, it’s more efficient
to condense it.
The Carbon Dioxide can then be chilled to
a liquid from at -40 Degrees Celsius and stored
in geological formations underground.
As a bonus, the process also cleans up about
60% of nitrous oxides that are a component
of smog.
Its a pretty incredible process that just
keeps getting better.
It’s like having a mirror that makes you
more handsome when you look at it.
FuelCell energy has been testing the concept
on a small scale for the last 5 months, but
they’re getting ready to scale it up to
hundreds of megawatts.
The process does use power from the fuel cell
to refrigerate the CO2, but it’s much more
manageable than the older methods, and the
fuel cell is still adding to the overall output
of the plant.
These fuel cells could also be used at oil
wells where it’s illegal to burn off the
natural gas byproduct but there’s no pipeline
to transport it.
Energy could be generated on site, and the
CO2 could be pumped into the ground where
it forces the oil out of the pores of the
rocks and makes the well more efficient.
Of course burning petroleum products would
release more CO2, so in that scenario it’s
not clear how much the technology would actually
be helping.
But at least it shows a lot of promise for
keeping the cost of clean energy down while
more renewable sources are brought online.
If this ends up cleaning up Coal and Natural
Gas plants, would renewable energy even be
worth it?
Trace has the answer to that right over here.
So do you think it’s a stopgap or a permanent
solution?
Let us know in the comments, and I’ll see
you next time on DNews